acs confessions
acs confessions yes confession all right
my girl is so [ __ ] [ __ ] at giving
ahead that i've turned to males to give
me slops
head from gay guys is always 10 10
it's always 10 10 better but the post
not clarity it makes me feel ill i can't
lie
commentary uni
bro it has to be covered dream someone
needs to finish cover oh
has to be coventry units so annoying
remember when i said someone sent me one
that was that was it one it was that one
disgraceful bro [ __ ] disgraceful
brother of uni man
[Music]
shot on the floor and wiped it
everywhere and blamed it on one of my
roommates
waiting for him to come back now lee's
unit
this has happened live bro
live
man just said
i just nodded on my own face essex uni
i'm not gonna laugh at that man bro
that's disgusting
bro
whoa
my boyfriend's twin brother rearranged
my guts
thinking i wouldn't notice that he's not
my boyfriend but i was aware the whole
time and played along with it because
why not he looks just like my [ __ ] so
it's not cheating
coventry uni
coventry uni again bro
for your face
[Laughter]
wow yes brother
it's not it just doesn't make sense it
can't be truthful bro but they're very
specific they are very very very
specific very specific
wow this one i read this one
and
it's more tough than it is funny because
imagine it as one of us in our
friendship group oh wow okay go on it's
tough bro yeah you're gone
my boys always wonder why i never chat
to women in the club or outside of
lectures etc but i think i'm asexual and
i know my boys won't understand it's not
like i don't find women attractive
because i do i just have no desire to
sleep with anyone wolverhampton uni
being asexual must be tough boys that's
literally just like post not clarity
forever forever
that must be tough and i don't just look
at and you think she's buff yeah but
nothing happens down here yeah i don't
care
who do you talk to about something like
that bro
no one i guess you're just that's just
you
that's why i said that's tough man
that's tough
someone just wrote i like incest oxford
uni
wild times brother
wild
wild times
sometimes when i get high i pretend to
be gal on dating apps manchester uni
i would love nah i would love to see the
play-by-play on tinder i would love to
ah fanboy i paid money to see that how
do you stop yourself from getting lost
in that
taking on the role full time full time
yeah
uh bro
if someone says that the right sweet
time
and you get a little tingle in your
mingle that's weird yeah man you're lost
you don't know which way is up
oh god oh
this one's sweetened me
you know that circle beef burger thing
around a girl's nipples damn areolas
[ __ ] turns me on
i always ask if if she has big areolas
before dating women not trying to waste
any time london met uni wow
damn
damn areas
[Music]
yo wow
that is two man you've said it before
madame f kings mandem have
kinks brother it's not normal man i need
to know what the ariel is saying before
i even talk to you because it's
it's a deal breaker bro
nuts
no it just doesn't make sense
that doesn't make sense all right when
i'm bored i use the spoons in my in our
dorm kitchen to play with my [ __ ] in the
toilet i rinse them quickly and put them
back when i'm done bed fishy uni
i told you fam bedford's cracked
bedford is cracked man says
that's how i know it's true
because i could see it in my head
man drops a [ __ ] and it gets a spoon
just starts playing with it
oh my god
like siri or something
oh
bullet coco pops quickly you can tell
he's scurry's back once he's snapped
back to reality he scurries about rizzo
and puts it back what a disgusting
[ __ ] human being that's just
i could never find out my boy did that
and let me use the spoon
i'm going prison it's arms it's arms
it has to be arms
i really like this guy
but when he linked he had a micro penis
which i was willing to overlook if he
could use it properly but his dick
smelled so bad i almost threw up i
immediately turned away and started
crying so hard he asked me what was
wrong and now i feel bad
manchester met university wow
[Music]
tough that actually is really tough
tough i turned around it's like crying
crying and he's asking her what's wrong
babes
your dick is small and it stinks
that's what's wrong she could never say
that he would jump off a bridge oh 100
100 jump off a [ __ ] bridge
[ __ ] man
thing is though i don't think when
people say i was willing to overlook if
you had to use it like i don't think
people treat it yes though what micro
penis is i i have there's no using it
i've seen the documentary fam there is
no using it yeah what ducky battery is
that oh i don't know what it's called
but i all remember my man had to
literally bash like it was a [ __ ]
he had to get a couple fingers he
couldn't grab it yeah he had to get a
couple fingers and like because he was
trying to get himself hard
um nah because a lady he went to see one
artist and she makes penis molds okay so
he had to like get hard and then stick
his dick in her in a sculpt like a mold
so then it would be a sculpture okay of
course but in order to get himself hard
he was literally laying back like that
because they were showing everything he
was laying back in the soviet one leg up
here yeah his dick and he was like that
rubbing it like actually rubbing like a
clip literally flickered like a bean to
get a heart
grab it
it's tiny fam his name was lawrence i
remember
yo that's tough that's tough i'll do the
last one cool
i'm the top performing student in my
class but during my spare time i enjoy
being spit by multiple men
i could be given a lecture about biology
at i could be given a lecture about
biology at 3 and swallowing multiple
nuts by 4 30. it's like i have a split
personality dr jekyll and mrs ho ucl
matt
must be nice
mad
mad wow that's cool though i think
that's cool it depends on who you ask i
think that's cool yeah but obviously it
depends on who you are yeah it's true i
think it's very cool but yeah some
people won't
a lot of people won't
how does she frequently find the man is
it the same guys because that's the
thing if i'm spit roasted yeah save me
and you spit right to someone i'm not
doing it with you again again yeah yeah
it's like so one time yeah yeah yeah
yeah i know what you mean yeah i know
what you mean otherwise we might as well
be a throuple
i'm not just banging yes with you all
the time yeah that's weird brother
that's gay
at a certain point he's gay yeah
i've seen your tour more downtown than
i've seen vagina yeah yeah he's gay
yeah
so um
yeah how does she continuously find the
groups bro she just mis she just must be
word on the street
i'm here for it to be fair
because it may it feels going on road
that much yeah you know you're coming up
yeah you know what i mean you know
there's going to be a night out yeah
yeah you see her she sees you
like yeah tonight's the night tonight
the group chat it's our night
fellas
strap up it's our night
doctor jekyll's up yeah yeah
that was acs confessions for this week